hey this is presh talwalkar
on the morning of january 1st a hospital
nursery has three boys and some number
of girls
that night a woman gives birth to a
child and the child is placed in the
nursery
on january 2nd a statistician conducts a
survey and selects a child at random
from the nursery
the survey includes the newborn child
and every child in the nursery from
january 1st
the randomly selected child is a boy
what is the probability the child born
on january 1st was a boy
this problem has been asked as an
interview question for technical jobs
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
i'll get started with the common
misconception
the answer is not 50
while it is true that there is an equal
50 chance that the newborn child is a
boy or a girl
that is not the probability you're
looking for
the question is asking for the
probability of a newborn boy
given that the statistician randomly
picked a boy
how is this different
imagine the nursery started with zero
boys
if the statistician randomly picked a
boy
you would know the newborn must have
been a boy
that would be a hundred percent
probability
in general
because the statistician randomly
selected a boy
it is more likely that the newborn child
was a boy
intuitively the probability will be
greater than 50 percent
now let's calculate it and see what it
is
the problem does not specify the number
of girls at the beginning but we'll
assume three girls and see where this
calculation goes
so we start out with three girls and
three boys
there's is a 50 chance that the newborn
child is a boy
this makes for three girls and four boys
there's also a 50 chance that the
newborn is a girl which makes for four
girls and three boys
so what's the probability of selecting a
boy in each case
in the top range there are four boys out
of seven children total
this is a four out of seven chance and
we multiply that by the 50 chance of
being in this branch of having a boy
this is the probability of selecting a
boy and having the newborn child be a
boy
in the bottom branch there are three
boys out of seven children
and we need to multiply by the 50 chance
that the child born was a girl
this is the probability of selecting a
boy and having the newborn child be a
girl
so what's the probability of selecting a
boy this is the sum of these two
probabilities
this will be equal to three and a half
divided by seven and this makes sense
intuitively we're either going to have
three or four boys so on average we have
three and a half boys and we're always
going to have seven children so we have
three and a half out of seven and that's
a 50 chance
so what's the probability we want to
calculate
we want to know what's the probability
of having a newborn child given that we
selected a boy
this is the probability of the top
branch divided by the sum of the two
probabilities of the two branches in
other words it's the probability of
selecting a boy and have it be a newborn
boy
and
divided by the probability of selecting
a boy
so we take the ratio of the probability
of the top range divided by the sum of
the two probabilities
this simplifies to 4 out of 7 which is
approximately
57.1 percent so this is larger than 50
as we expected
now what would happen we assumed three
girls in this case but what would happen
in general
let's assume we have g girls
we start out with g girls and three boys
there's a 50 chance we have a boy
which would result in g girls and four
boys
there's a 50 chance we have a girl which
results in g plus one girls and three
boys
in the top branch there's a four divided
by g plus four chance of selecting a boy
and we multiply that by the fifty
percent chance of the top branch having
a boy
this is the probability of selecting a
boy and have it be a newborn boy
in the bottom branch we have three boys
divided by g plus four children in total
we multiply by the 50 probability of the
branch this is the probability of
selecting a boy and having a newborn
girl
so what's the probability of selecting a
boy this is the sum of the two
probabilities of these two branches
this is equal to three point five
divided by g plus four
intuitively we either have three or four
boys the next day happening with equal
chance so we have three and a half boys
on average and we divide that by the
total number of children which will
always be g plus four
so what's the probability that we want
to calculate the probability of having a
newborn boy given that we selected a boy
at random
this is the ratio of the top branch
divided by the sum of the two branches
so we put in these two
probabilities and you can see that the g
plus 4 actually cancels out
this simplifies to be 4 over 7 which is
approximately
57.1 percent
so the two counter-intuitive things
going on in this problem one is that it
doesn't matter the number of girls we
start with and two the probability is
more than fifty percent
we can actually generalize the problem
one more step we start out with g girls
but let's assume we have b boys instead
of saying we have three boys let's say
we have b boys
in that case we'll go ahead and draw out
our tree
we'll count the number of boys and girls
we'll calculate the conditional
probabilities in each of these cases
we again calculate the probability of
selecting a boy
and then we calculate the probability of
having a newborn boy given that we
selected a boy
this all simplifies to be b plus one
over two b plus one
so as the number of boys increases
this ratio is going to approach one half
which is the 50 percent that we would
expect
so for example if you started out with
50 boys
then you would have an approximately
50.5 percent chance that the newborn
child was a boy if you selected it so
that's pretty close to 50 it's slightly
more
but it's a very counterintuitive problem
it doesn't matter the number of girls
you start with and the probability is
more than 50 percent
did you figure this out thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel i make videos on math and
game theory you can catch me on my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on facebook google plus and patreon you
can catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description